les coaches ça fait des mois que thuram
qui était un creux de la vague
honnêtement je vois pas ce qu'on me
reproche je suis toujours à l'heure sur
le tournage toujours de bonne volonté au
taquet je connais mes personnages plus
personne ne voit c'est avec toi et ce
temps la vérité c'est quelque chose je
ne répondrai pas à n'importe qui c'est
vrai que ce genre faire exactement le
mort pour la justice des reconstitutions
sur des scènes de crime
quand le violent a prévenu qu'il y
aurait une vedette dans son équipe
j'ai aussi pourrait fermer la trêve
c'est faire le mort c'est pas anodin
vous être solide psychologiquement je
présente jeanrenaud d'oublier une scène
de crime n'est pas une scène de théâtre
c'est valable le juge je veux je connais
mon métier je suis professionnel avant
tout à coup vous êtes moins fort sans
lui je ne joue pas le personnage je suis
le personnage j'entends du bruit du
marteau quoi encore là bas je me défends
l'instinct de survie
si je veux qu'on retourne la scène
ensemble à touba clés sur internet est
pas bros vous attendez pas comment faire
la tête de seconde n'est pas capable de
tuer à la base une action c'est gotham
city cette commande
et c'est moi faire si tu as fait
négociateurs à juillet ce coup